[Musique]
en ce moment trois mille policiers sont
aux trousses de ces assaillants tout en
étant finalement dans cette opération
policière du plan de protection anti
terroriste a été relevé à son plus haut
niveau
les profils des suspects sont recherchés
qui sont en train de circuler
actuellement il ailleurs janvier le dos
était sous protection chant avec tes
sous protection a vu nos deux
brancardiers apporter une civière en
direction de ce supermarché la voilà
explosion on est encore voilà c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
les rues de paris sans complètement
saturé paris en fait n'a pas vu autant
de gens dans les rues depuis la
libération
à la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
le théâtre du bataclan où est survenu
recueillir des attaques se trouve
littéralement au coin de la rue si donc
un périmètre de sécurité qui a été
établi des politiques sont aussi
présents en très grand nombre
on ira vous voir très souvent ce sont
des élections qui vont se vivre ce soir
en famille monsieur trudeau et avec sa
femme sophie grégoire ses trois enfants
et sa mère margaret 22h37 radio canada
prévoit que le gouvernement libéral sera
majoritaire
l'aide médicale à mourir demeure quoi
qu'en dise la cour suprême un sujet
hautement litigieux les patients doivent
avoir au moins 18 ans et être capable de
consentir
ils devront rédiger une demande écrite
sa photo a été placardée sur les
panneaux des autoroutes du québec et
c'était quelques mètres à peine de l'une
d'entre elles en bordure de l'a 40 que
ces restes ont été trouvés
c'est une affaire qui a touché désolé
indignée la population québécoise et de
façon plus intense les trifluviens
hormis ce sont personnes qui meurent
vingt quatre mois dans la mer wikleaks
l'humanitaire et ils ne sont pas au bout
de leur peine car le droit d'asile en
europe est loin d'être automatique
laisse thibout est resté de marbre
en attendant le juge carol st-cyr lui
indiquer le chemin de la prison
on a vocation qui n'a demandé aucun
traitement de faveur pour sa célèbre
cliente
nous allons consacrer notre émission à
jacques parizeau et à son héritage pour
l'économie du québec
très souvent il se présentait avant tout
comme enseignant plutôt qu ancien
premier ministre alors c'est pour dire
combien il a aimé son métier
masson
pas fou
en jean
[Musique]